wait it's how long until the next season
well that's bull shirt all right
look good place season three I'm quick
little bit of housekeeping I missed the
latest episode of Gotham I had some
technical issues I'm gonna do a double
review next week when that rolls around
yeah yeah I think the other thing I
mentioned I know a stop
the good play season 3 tiny bit a bit of
housekeeping real quick first I had
technical issues I was not able to
record my review for the most recently
aired episode of Gotham next week I'm
just gonna do a double review so I don't
have to read work my entire schedule for
the rest of the week so moving on from
that before I get into it let me say
this if you have not seen the good place
it is impossible to talk about season 3
without in some way spoiling the first
two seasons season even before I get
into spoilers for season 3 itself so you
really should be caught up on the show
and actually you should be caught up on
season 3 as well if you're gonna watch
this because I'm just gonna talk about
the whole thing so yeah you have been
warned
so one thing I gotta say I am super
impressed about with this show is its
ability to completely blow up it's
status quo and start with a completely
new premise and setting and sort of
parameters every single season three
seasons in a row now to status quo blow
ups it's really impressive and it's the
sort of thing that normally I'd be
paranoid about I'd be like they can't
keep pulling this off except that
theoretically I would have said they
couldn't even have pulled this off once
much less you know twice now over the
course of three seasons and also it
helps that from what I've heard Michael
sure has said he has a definitive
endgame of mine again I couldn't find a
direct quote from him I've heard some
people say he's gonna do five seasons I
can't find a direct quote from him
confirming that but I did find quotes
from him saying that he knows where this
is going so that plus the goodwill that
the first three seasons have built up
yeah I'm not too worried about where
things go from here so I'll talk a
little bit more about that I think
towards the tail end when I get to the
end of the season so overall this season
taking place on earth our characters
alive again at least for a while
you know trying to you know get things
to to work out for them and Michael
really trying his darndest and the bad
place trying to trip them up every
possible step of the way I think if I
was gonna compare this to the other two
seasons I probably put it at the bottom
but not be
cuz it's bad it's really good I think
the thing is is that because it's set on
earth it lacks a little bit of that just
fantastical nature I guess since the
first one took place in well what we
thought was the good place and then the
second one took place in what we knew to
be the bad place and now just to be on
earth the setting is a little less
inherently interesting but the situation
is still interesting and the characters
are still great so I mean like it still
works it's not I didn't like it wasn't
until I finished the season I actually
thought what what how would i rank is
that I thought I guess it's the bottom
season but like that's a weird thing for
me to say cuz I have really enjoyed it I
think that speaks a heck of a lot to how
strong the show has been even prior to
this and up to this point the characters
are all great and like when I did my
video about you know just rambling about
why I love the show anyway I'll do a
little link up up there for that you
know I bought all these characters and
why they are fantastic and they're all
still great we also get some nice work
being done with with some of the new
characters or characters that would get
me to spend more time with I feel like
we got a bit more time with Sean which I
rather enjoyed he's he's so smart he's a
wonderfully hateable antagonist I really
like him a lot and then there's Bob we
we got to see Mindy and Derrick again I
had been hoping we'd get that and there
that was really nice we've got a
cheetah's girlfriend whose name is
suddenly escaping me the one that he had
on earth for a little bit before he died
he and Eleanor finally hooked up like
for realsies and but she was really good
I liked her a lot she was super likable
and just charming and fun and she worked
with Gd really well there's some bonkers
episodes in this season - I love the one
in Janet's void where so you've got
Janet portraying everybody and I dug up
some of the behind the scenes stuff and
it was awesome because they had all the
actors play all the parts for the sea
and then the actress who plays Janet do
it again as them so that she could match
their rhythm and their cadence in their
line delivery it's really amazing and
super seamless like about halfway
through the episode I kind of forgot all
these people were being played by the
same person it was really well done
and Janet's pain - my favorite anyway
they are all great though they're all
fantastic characters and also even
though I do consider as I think the the
week season like comparatively only it's
still great it does have my single
favorite moment so far in the show
and that's the whole Jeremy Berra me
explanation I love not only do I love
that explanation of how time works I
love Chiti so much right tells this this
dot over the I what what is that
and Michael tries to explain it in just
Jeannie's face that broke me I I'm done
and I mean look Liz can tell you I've
kind of adopted that a little bit what
I'm just like nope I'm out I'm done
it's so perfect I just showed that to
DePaul who's he hasn't been on the show
at a long time and he just had another
kid so I don't know if we're ever gonna
see Paul again but you go back to the
other ones he he used to run my gaming
group and I actually showed him that
clip ago Paul this is what it's like
with you as the des the the DM sometimes
who's just I'm done I just that add that
ah love it but you know a lot of good
stuff besides that we got Trevor my
Rudolph really got some great stuff to
do as the judge so that was all I'm
really cool it's a little bit slow to
start the season
I think um you know as it's sort of
laying out the you know them trying to
you know work out what they're trying to
do on earth having things pick up once
they basically catch Michael and Janet
you know with the door but part of that
it was still good it but it did take a
little bit longer
kind of to kind of get going especially
if I were compared to say season two
which like really hit the ground running
by showing us right in the first episode
how often Michael had to keep resetting
everything I also really liked how
bittersweet the ending of this season is
with Gd but the choice being made to
wipe Gigi's memory just as he and
Eleanor finally not only like fallen for
each other again but have gotten
comfortable with it like Eleanor and
Chitti being comfortable around each
other is really charming and I'm I
usually surprised how much I like this
because normally the whole thing of
characters you know doing a will they
won't they then they get together and
then the show breaks them up normally
that ticks me off because I'm it's like
well you just want to try and recapture
you know that will they won't take
chemistry again after you decided to
actually hook them up and so you blew it
up and you know this is this is stupid
this is practically a wreck on like what
was the point but that's not the case
here so my normal objections that I'd
have to this kind of thing don't apply
because it is played as a bittersweet
note and it doesn't feel like they're
trying to reset to recapture that
initial build of the relationship again
they're playing it for the sadness and
hopefully that'll track across season
four as well yeah there's some other
code I liked the the glimpse at
accounting and how all that worked and
the amazing thing he's he's doing
something no human has ever done and
it's not a weird sex thing oh oh yes it
is
oh alright then like that I really like
the the the one with Doug was okay I
just felt like that the joke of how
miserable Doug's life was by the virtue
of him trying to be a good person we got
hammered into the ground a little bit um
but uh it was obviously very plot
necessary oh boy thinking I feel like
I'm nitpicking this a lot I don't know
why what's wrong with me why do I do
that how many points am i losing for the
fact that I nitpick something that I
love
haha I'm so going on a bad place yeah
boy so yeah shows great shows great
season was great I'm surprised that I'm
continuing to like the the sort of
push-pull between Janet and Jason and I
think largely because it's being used to
develop Janet and have her continue to
evolve and that's being continually
acknowledged as well with our sort of
like yeah I don't even know what I am
anymore as I'm feeling all these things
and it's weird and it's messing me up
but it's also kind of cool and actually
I really love her moment of her kind of
her little pep talk that she gives
Eleanor you know right at the end about
how everything is chaos and it's
pandemonium but those things and the
people and the relationships that you
can hold on to even if it's only for a
little bit is what grounds you and it's
what keeps you going and that glimmer of
feeling the connection even in all this
chaos is something magical and that was
really great I like that a lot
that was a good sentiment so I think
I'll wrap it up there it's really good I
really do like this show I think it's
it's definitely one of the smartest and
best written shows currently airing I
don't want to say it's my favorite show
currently airing but boy this thing is
really great the good place season three
you seen it what you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it whole bunch of stuff we
can do because it's buttons links
there's one to the patreon um there's my
Pio boxes down there a whole bunch of
other ways to check out besides give
them a look if you feel like it if you
don't that is okay because at the end of
the day you are the council I just run
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]